♪ ♪ ♪
- Les prochaines nuits risquent
d'être féeriques. Le ciel nous
offrira l'un de ses plus beaux
spectacles, les Perséides :
une  pluie d'étoiles filantes.
OLIVER HERNANDEZ, directeur,
Planétarium Rio Tinto Alcan
- Ce sont des petits grains
de sable qui se frottent
à l'atmosphère terreste à
des vistesses colossales qui
frisent les 60 km par seconde,
ce qui est énorme.
- Une poussière née du sillage
de la comète swift Tuttle
qui rend visite au soleil
tous les 133 ans.
- Ces petites particules, en
fait, vont se frotter à
l'atmosphère terrestre et
devenir des étoiles filantes,
des petits bolides, en fait,
et des... et venir s'éclairer
tout simplement dans le ciel
le soir.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Elles défilent au-dessus de
nos têtes à des vitesses
vertigineuses, entre 50 000 et
100 000 kilomètres à l'heure.
LOÏC QUESNEL, coordo. activ.
loi. scien. Plané. Rio Ti. Alcan
- La météo, elle n'est pas
parfaite. De toute façon,
mais...
- Mais cette année, on prédit
un très beau spectacle.
- Parce que la lune, qui parfois
peut être un petit peu
dérangeante quand elle est
pleine ou très lumineuse,
sera proche de la phase de
la nouvelle lune.
- Cependant il faudra composer
avec une météo capricieuse
et des risques d'orages.
Mais dès demain, il sera
possible de les observer.
- Cette année, le maximum est
dans la journée du 12 août,
mais on peut observer la nuit
qui va préceder : la nuit du
11 au 12 août et la nuit
suivante, du 12 au 13 août.
- Pour bien les voir, il faut
s'éloigner des lumières des
villes, choisir un endroit
dégagé et lever la tête vers
le ciel.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.